some people argue that large tech
companies are too big they are indeed
large Facebook has more active users
than our people in China Google handles
at least two trillion searches a year
why are these companies so big because
you and I use them we do that because we
get lots of value so saying they're too
big is to say they provide too much
value which doesn't make sense other
people argue the big tech makes too much
money
Facebook's 2017 profit was 16 billion
dollars about 40 percent of its revenue
does Facebook really need that much
money that's the wrong question only
about 10 to 20 percent of tech firms
ever make a profit so 80 to 90 percent
either break even or lose substantial
amounts of money the profits of the few
drive investors to endure the losses of
the many on average the tech sectors
returns are comparable to those of the
S&P 500 so when someone says that tech
companies are too big save you're
grateful you're getting great value and
competition for the future what do you
think should big tech be broken up let
us know your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI